in the last few days the issue of girl
students wearing a hijab in the southern
state of karnataka is taking an ugly
turn
these girls were stopped from going to
school because they were wearing a hijab
they campaigned and camped outside the
gates which didn't allow them to enter
the premises they say that it is a
violation of their fundamental right and
the right to freedom of religion which
is enshrined in the constitution of
india india is giving our rights to
follow our religion and their this
constitution itself giving a right to do
it then why they are stopping us to do
all those things so
they were confronted and challenged by a
large number of students from the
majority hindu community who are wearing
saffron trolls and scarves which is
associated with the hindu religion
muslims
there was stone pelting and the police
had to use patents to disperse them in
one place the police had to fire in the
air to disperse the violent crowd now
the last few years the muslim minority
community which is about 172 million
people about 14 percent of the country's
population feel persecuted by the
nationalist government of prime minister
modi and his parity
we have seen a widening a rapidly
widening of communal
communal tensions and divide in this
country over a religion and this
accentuates when there are local and
national elections around the corner in
the next few weeks some of the states
are going to the polls
uh campaigner for women's and a peace
prize winner malala yousafzai
campaigned and has tweeted about this
incident saying college is forcing us to
choose between studies and the hijab
refusing to let girls go to school in
their hijabs is horrifying
objectification of women persist for
wearing less or more indian leaders must
stop this marginalization of the muslim
women
now this issue is being discussed in
parliament and it is also in court but
it does have the potential to spiral out
of control and flare up in the rest of
the country